it's a great honor to host this special
appreciation of Stanley's immense talent
as a director he's considered by critics
who cares about critics anyway but done
and especially by his fellow filmmakers
to be one of the greatest directors that
has ever worked in our business he can
be mentioned in the same breath as John
Ford David Lean Hitchcock Fellini
Bergman could asawa yes he really does
belong in that elite group of directors
so what was he like to work with well of
course as an actor I can tell you that
he was absolutely extraordinary if and
it was a big if he trusted you I do
remember an instance before we started
shooting clockwork we were standing
outside Abbott's made the house that he
lived in in Boerum wood and I rather
innocently just asked him how he
directed his films because I'd sort of
been used to working with you know
Lindsay Anderson people from the theater
who were nurturing to actors
well he looked at me with a blank stare
and he said um gee milk I don't know
what I want but I do know what I don't
want of course I didn't really
understand what he was talking about at
the time but at the beginning of the
shoot I asked him if he had it any ideas
that he could give me for a particular
scene and he replied same blank stare
gee milk
I'm not rather meaning of course the
Royal Academy of Dramatic Arts a Drama
School well I was quite dumbfounded at
first and I thought well the best way to
treat this is with humour so I
immediately called for a call sheet and
said look at this stand says here hey s
Kubrick director how about a little
direction so he burst out laughing and
that's the way our relationship pretty
much was but I realize later when he
said this
I'm not Rada thing that I realize that's
actually he'd given me the greatest gift
of all he'd actually given me a blank
canvas to come in and just do whatever I
wanted make a complete idiot of myself
if I wanted to and it would not seem
ridiculous to him well pretty much all
the time but not all the time anyway
there's so many Stan Lee stories of
course and we're going to hear a few of
them tonight I remember once
particularly going into his study and he
had these earphones on and I thought oh
and he shushed me I wanted to ask him
something and I thought well what on
earth is he listening to oh I know he's
listening to the latest herbert von
carrion recording of Beethoven's 9th and
this went on for like 20 minutes
eventually he took him off and said
another near miss at Heathrow
really no sorry about that on the set
with him it was amazing
well he was a little paranoid about air
travel and actually it was right this
you know near misses all the time going
on at Heathrow mmm in the end scene in
the middle of the film somewhere and we
were all very pleased with ourselves and
you know it went very well we were we
came to the beating and rape of the
writers wife seen in the film and I was
rather exhausted and he was sort of
exhausted too and we sat around for five
days thinking what in Hell's name are we
gonna do in the script it said something
like the drugs throw liquor through a
plate-glass window and that was it I
know I was quite boring and realistic
and nothing to do with what we'd been
shooting anyway on the fifth day just
sitting around Stanley came up to me and
said can you dance boom that's all I
needed I went immediately into an improv
of singing in the rain whap Bank smack
boom kick and Stanley was looking dead
the joy on his face was absolutely
immense he was loving it laughing
because he had an incredibly black
wonderful sense of humor and I got one
of those gestures from him which either
meant an actor was fired or Malcolm
something I was doing right was okay he
got me into the car we drove back to his
office called New York bought the rights
to singing in the rain and we came back
and it took a week to shoot the sequence
but it was a memorable one